What is the best thing to do for pain naturally without drugs?
Very common question that we get. I don't want to take Tylenol. I don't want to take
Agile. I don't want to take a prescription drug medication. What can I do for naturally without drugs?
Can I use the pain program on the right? Yes? Does it work really well? No,
But it can for some people we've had testimonies of people said they use the pain program on the right and it worked wonders
But that's a smaller percentage quite honestly
The pain program is probably not gonna cut you severe pain from you know, musculoskeletal pain to
pain from cancer
You're gonna need something stronger
Well, can I just take anti-inflammatory nutrients like carcubid and Boswellia and Stiggy Nettel and
Things like that maybe so we've had testimonies of people who've used beta-lin, which is the
aloevia product that's patented from Beats
It's an anti-inflammatory that if you know had chronic pain for their whole life and it started using that two or three a day
And it took their pain away and people use carcubid and other inflammatory flavonoids like in clear in flamm and it took their pain away
But severe pain usually is going to need something else to break the pain cycle and
Sometimes you only need to take something for a short period of time and then the other things these natural things that I just mentioned may work and be a
supplement for you
But typically with cancer pain severe pain
You're gonna need something else. Is there anything else natural that I could use?
Well, not really
Artica is something that people have used for pain
But again, it's not gonna be the same as taking a medication. That's really gonna break that pain cycle
THC which is the psychoactive form of
Marijuana can be used for pain and people have used that for chronic pain
That can be beneficial, but it has side effects the side effects of THC might not be damaging ones liver
But it can make your life miserable because it makes you so loopy. You can't stand it. So that has side effects
So it is a difficult situation to be in when you're faced with this chronic pain and you tried everything natural and nothing is touching it
This is where I do think that God has given us medication for a purpose and
It can help get you through that that time
Many times you just need to break the pain cycle and
Sometimes the pain cycle is constantly ramped up because you have a tumor that's directly impacting
Under a pathway and that's where we might have to take more extreme measures with surgery or something like that
But it is difficult, you know, that is a common question we get
But I wish there was a better answer for this that hey this herb magically takes our pain away
But for very severe pain. There's very little in that category from a natural perspective